That's not even me chewing!
I was muted!
Welcome back!
Oh god...
Hold on...
Let me restart.
Welcome back!
Master!
Welcome to Peggle.
I say...
I say with my squeaky voice.
I'm so sorry.
I have tea here.
Oh my god, I can't do this anymore.
Please.
What the?
I can't do this anymore.
Okay, there we go.
Very good.
I'm a headcrab, obviously.
My voice has been kind of not so great lately.
Which is not good, because I have a concert.
Like this weekend.
So I'm...
I'm...
Trying to rest my voice a little bit this week.
You'll hear the pegging sound...
I'm sorry, peggling sound effects.
Don't worry.
You guys have to remember there's an L.
It's peggle.
You know?
I was reading somebody's comment.
I was reading...
It wasn't me!
I'll turn the sound effects back on.
When it's time.
Finn!
Welcome to Babusha Vacuum!
Sure, blame chat.
What?
Yes!
It wasn't me!
I was just reading!
But yeah.
I just felt like playing peggle today.
You know.
Just when you feel like playing peggle.
But this is peggle extreme.
Which I think it has...
It's kind of freaky.
Look at that.
And then when you have the sound effects on.
Like who's chewing this?
I mean I know it's him.
But like who?
Who?
I was just reading girl.
We know what you read.
Oh my gosh.
Do you guys want to hear an update?
Do you guys want to hear an update to the book I've been reading recently?
Or rather listening to?
Addie!
Thank you for the 10 gift.
Thank you!
So it's the sequel to the Minotaur milking farm.
And this one is called Sweet Berries.
Such a lust for peggle!
Really putting the freaky and freaky ghost in it.
Yeah!
There's a sequel?
Oh my gosh!
There's a whole series!
Yeah!
Sweet Berries.
And it's...
About a mothman.
And it's about a lady.
Literally the first line is I'm too horny to think.
I'm too horny to think.
That's the first line of the book.
And then...
And then she...
She...
They also mention the Minotaur farm.
It's kind of crazy they mention the milking farm.
I guess because she has like a Minotaur co-worker.
And he's just like I gotta go to the farm.
Or else I'm gonna explode.
And we're like... whoa!
I say we.
It's me.
And like... you know... the...
The lady in the book.
Maybe I don't even...
I don't even remember if she was surprised or not.
It's me.
I'm the one who's like...
Whoa!
And then she like...
Has... she's like...
She's like... oh my gosh.
I'm also gonna explode.
And then there's like a Mothman.
But she doesn't know it's a Mothman.
Outside her window watching her while she's like...
Having freaky time with herself.
Right?
And then...
She's just like...
Oh my gosh.
There's someone watching me outside the window.
This is kind of like...
The best ever.
You'll always be my little pegchamp Minotaur.
No!
Yeah.
Mothman out of nowhere.
Oh my gosh.
And...
Um...
So I guess that happens a couple times.
I don't know.
I keep falling asleep during the book.
Then I...
Then I started back up where I think I left off.
Um...
And...
There's one time she's just like...
I'm not gonna do...
Okay, this is the last time I'm gonna be freaky in front of my window.
And have this Mothman watch.
But she still doesn't know it's a Mothman.
And...
She...
She's just like, tomorrow I'm gonna sign up for Growler.
Which I guess is the...
Is the furry land...
Dating app.
And...
And so she's like, this is the last time.
This is the last time.
And...
Have you tried out Peglin?
What's Peglin?
Peglin.
And um...
Hold on.
I haven't even gotten to my favorite line of the book.
To my favorite line in the book yet.
Cause I was like, falling asleep.
And then she said this line.
Cause it's an audio book, right?
I listen to it while I'm going to sleep.
And I literally snapped out of like...
That in between state I was in.
And I just was laughing.
I was like, no way she just said that.
No way she just said that!
I'm milking minotaurs.
I don't need to know this line.
You do!
You do.
So basically she's just like...
Oh my gosh.
She was like imagining...
The guy outside her window.
She's like, I know this is probably a bad idea.
He could be like...
He could burst through my front door right now.
He could be a murderer.
But you know what?
Right now...
I'm freaking so I don't care.
And...
She like talks to him.
But he only responds and clicks.
So she'll be like...
She'll be like...
Do you like what you see?
And he'll be like...
And she just has to...
Take it as a yes.
I guess.
At one point...
I'm like in my head too.
While I'm imagining this.
I'm imagining it not as...
On the cover of the book...
It's like a sexy Mothman.
He's got abs.
And he's got...
A conventionally attractive face.
Stuff like that.
But in my brain I'm imagining...
Not a Mothman but a fly man.
And his giant fly eyes.
Bugging out.
And his little mouth.
Like you know how the mouth...
Kind of stick out.
Like that.
And I'm imagining him doing that thing with his hands.
That flies do when they clean his hands.
Because she keeps saying...
I can hear his humming.
And I'm like...
Like a whirring sound.
And I'm just like...
What is this bug doing?
Like...
But anyway...
She's like...
Super into this guy...
From the window.
Sounds like Batara's type.
Right?
I'm no longer shocked by what you read now.
You freaky ghost maid.
Yeah.
AKA Peggy.
Peggy.
But um...
Is this a man sized moth or a moth sized man?
It's a man sized...
Mothman.
And...
Anyway...
Okay my favorite line.
And sorry.
I have to say a bad word.
It's been 10 minutes though.
So YouTube won't bonk me.
Oh sorry.
You can't hear the little birds chirping anymore.
Okay.
We're not...
It's literally on the levels of Picasso.
Okay?
It's so...
Oh my gosh.
Okay so...
She's like getting freaky with herself.
And then like...
I don't know...
He somehow...
Reaches from the window.
But he's still shrouded in darkness.
She can't see him.
But something...
Starts touching her.
I don't know if it's like his really long moth tongue or what.
I have no idea.
But she's like...
She's like oh my gosh.
This guy...
I need...
I can't even say this.
She says to him...
She says...
She says mad outside the window.
I need to...
I need you...
Oh god.
I'm so sorry for saying this out loud.
But if I had to hear it...
You'd do too.
She said...
She says...
I need you...
You'd do too.
Don't fuck me until I'm boneless.
What does that mean?
I literally had to repeat it.
I was falling asleep.
I was like did she say boneless?
Like a chicken wing.
Oh my god.
I'm crying.
It was so out of nowhere.
I was like what are you talking about?
Like a pizza.
No.
Oh my gosh.
It was so funny.
I don't know what she meant by that truly.
I'm like I don't...
I don't...
I don't know.
Do ghosts have bones?
She's not a ghost.
She's a lady.
Like one boneless woman.
Someone gets paid to read these aloud.
I know.
And she's really into it too.
She does such a good job.
But please be honest with me.
If you were having a time...
If you were having relations and someone said I need you to f me until I'm boneless.
How would you feel?
That's messed up.
That's how we get slime girls.
I guess so, right?
I'm not...
Confused.
Motivated.
Wow.
I'm boneless.
I don't understand what it means.
But then afterwards she's like even though she was like this is the last time I'm doing this.
He doesn't show up for a couple of days.
And she gets mad.
She gets mad.
She's just like because he doesn't like me anymore.
What the hell.
This guy doesn't want to stand outside my window.
What?
But then she's like at work doing something.
I don't even know what her job is.
I guess it's like event hosting or event planning or something.
And a moth guy comes up to her.
And she's like Hi moth guy.
And also this city has laws.
So if you have outward outward genitalia you have to wear pants.
But if you're an innie as she calls it.
Like it's a god damn belly button.
She said if it's an innie you don't have to wear pants.
And so the moth man is an innie.
And she's just like ah he's not wearing pants.
Oh
but don't you worry guys.
Next week there's going to be an election.
Where they'll probably hire a new mayor.
And the new mayor wants everybody to wear pants.
So outward, outies, innies everybody is wearing pants.
Sorry there's not going to be any you know any favoritism for those who have innies okay.
Oh the new mayor.
I support the new mayor.
And so she meets the moth man and he's like super duper shy.
He comes up to her and he's like hello hello hello hello hello.
And she's just like hi.
And then he starts then she like says something and he starts going and he starts clicking again and she's like you are the guy outside my window.
And that's where I fell asleep.
And so I'll update you guys again.
So I don't know where it'll go from here.
That's about an hour into the five hours of the book so.
Yeah.
That's where I'm at I think.
How could you fall asleep to such a masterpiece.
Oh man.
You guys ready for Peggle?
Let's adventure.
Whoa.
Oh.
Oh no.
I accidentally clicked adventure.
I accidentally clicked it earlier.
Wait the adventure.
We don't get the story.
Hit all orange pegs to win.
You have ten shots.
Ten shots everybody.
We should get the adventure on the next one though.
What the hell is this thing?
Oh hold on.
You guys for Peggle I have to get comfortable okay?
Much better.
Okie dokie.
From Half Life.
Mmm.
I'm up here.
Can you see me?
Alright we gotta get all the orange pegs.
All the orange balls.
Looking forward to this stream.
I also recommend Pegglin if you enjoy this.
Chat seems to be big fans of Mint's Peggle.
Mpeg.
Not the Mpeg.
I'm up here.
Can you see me?
Hold on.
Maybe hold on.
Can you see me now?
My big ol' eyes.
I'm doing that thing with my hands like I'm a fly.
Minto leaving us boneless.
Not the boneless.
Where did the ghost go?
Can you spot her chat?
Can you spot the ghost?
Ok.
We're gonna do this first try.
Oh!
The sound effects.
Oh my gosh.
There.
Let me know if it's too loud.
Oh my god.
Ah!
We were so close to making it in the hole.
Hold on.
There we go.
That should be better.
The Mothman is... POV.
The Mothman is looking through your window.
No!
Bing bing.
No no no no!
No!
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
Oh yeah.
No.
Oh.
How many?
We have eight balls left.
Oh my gosh.
Is this gonna be hard?
Is this gonna be difficult?
Oh gosh.
I have to sneeze.
No!
Do you think she heard me sneeze while I was looking out...
while I was looking through her window?
Do you think she heard me?
Bless you.
Thank you.
Oh nice.
Nice.
Oh!
Oh gosh.
No!
Guys!
This is too difficult.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
Oh yes!
Yes!
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
You got the ball in the bucket.
This returns the ball to the ball-a-tron.
Thank you.
You got this Minto.
Peg them until they're boneless.
What was the first Saucy Jack book you read?
Was it Chuck Ting?
It was...
I think a billionaire book.
I can't remember to be honest.
I started normal where I was listening to...
like Maze Runner.
And I was like... hmm.
I don't know what got me started.
I don't know.
I've just been a little freaky.
I can't stop the freak.
Oh my gosh.
We got it.
Oh nice.
Nice.
I was gonna say we gotta get in here.
Alright.
Oh my gosh.
Three in a row!
How are we doing this?
Oh!
Oh my god!
Just one left you guys.
Just one left.
You guys ready for this?
Are you guys ready for this?
It's gonna be loud.
I can turn it down.
I don't think it'll be so loud.
It'll probably be fine.
It won't be loud.
If it's loud, I'll just yell over it.
Oh my god!
100,000!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, it's gonna happen.
No!
Cleverly done.
Who the heck was that?
I didn't jinx it!
Whoa.
Hit the bricks.
This level has bricks.
Clear the orange bricks and orange pegs to pass the level.
Alright.
I'm feeling lucky.
Cleverly done.
Pink.
Pink one.
Roll.
Nice.
Oh, so close.
Actually, I'm gonna start over here.
Never mind.
Long shot!
Mothman said it.
Oh, so close.
I got some style points.
I'm styling!
Do you guys actually want me over here too?
Or...
It's kinda lonely.
It's kinda empty here, right?
What should I put there?
Is Peggle's story also an erotic thriller?
I don't think so.
Why are there two of me?
Voice surfers, please.
I want you to know I read the game's title as Pregle.
Oh, like the Pringles!
Nah, I'm sorry to make you hungry.
Some Family Guy clips.
Oh my gosh!
Come on!
Get that one!
What?
So rude!
What can I put?
Oh, I can put a frog.
Yeah, I can put a frog gif.
Hold on.
Perfect!
Perfect, perfect, perfect.
There we go.
Okay.
What the?
Wait, I moved a little.
How did I move?
There we go.
Okay.
Now we're good.
This one.
Style points.
No, no, no.
That one sucked, you guys.
That was terrible.
That was the worst.
The worst one ever.
Happy birthday!
Whose birthday is it?
Star Creator!
It's my birthday.
I can't think of a better way to spend it.
That extreme peggling!
It's an L.
There's an L on there.
Don't forget the L.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Star Creator.
Happy birthday!
How are you guys doing today?
It's Monday.
Did you guys have a good weekend?
We're one day closer to Minto 3.0.
One day closer.
One day more.
Tired?
Nah, it's okay.
Doing alright watching a Minto stream?
It was alright?
Just got back from a wedding?
Ooh la la.
I had a normal weekend.
Normal can be good sometimes.
Yeah, just come chill with Minto.
Get free ball, free ball, free ball!
We got two balls left and two things, you guys.
Oh gosh, will we make it?
Two balls left.
Let's get rid of this guy.
It teased us a little.
What a tease!
It's okay, we can't miss this one.
Ready?
Sorry to backseat, but if you get the hunter to shoot an object with eyes felchat rounds, you can throw it back on the gravity gun to insta-kill it.
Huh?
What does that mean?
Let's hang in while refueling.
Are you getting gas?
Gas, gas, gas, gas.
Half life, full life consequences.
Here we go!
I actually...
I don't know...
Come on!
You didn't even try!
Cleverly done.
I know nothing about half life.
I know...
I'm more excited about the... Oh, this one's so cute!
I'm more excited about the portal levels.
Magic peg!
Are you guys ready for the magic peg?
Magic peeeeg!
There's a half life peggle.
Yeah!
And it's free!
This is free, actually, you guys.
It's Peggle Extreme.
You can get it on Steam for free.
Isn't that so awesome?
Thanks John Steam Man!
Everybody say thank you to John Steam Man.
Dang, so close.
Okay, here we go.
Let's get a magic... Oh, just kidding.
Just kidding.
Nice!
John Freeman!
No, no.
I'm ready.
You ready?
Okay, this one's for you, Magic Sword King!
What'd it do?
Oh, Super God!
Super God.
Oh, see if we...
We could have it go all the way up and get that one up there.
Long shot.
Or not.
Bing bong!
Bing!
I just noticed this one right here.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Oh!
That might have been my best shot ever.
What is this thing called?
Wait, is this the head crab in the background?
I'm cooking.
Yeah, that was such a good shot.
Holy moly.
Little head crab.
He's crunching on you.
You know what this would make?
A good popcorn box.
A popcorn bucket.
Like if you agree.
Okay, we're gonna do the bounce bounce.
Wait, there's another green!
Oh, we almost had it!
For free?
Oh!
No.
Like the dune one?
Yeah, like the dune one.
Guys, this might be it.
Never mind.
Guys, this is it!
This is the run!
Ho, ho, ho, ho!
Come on!
100,000!
Oh my god, wait!
Wait!
No, no, no!
I didn't see- My cursor was covering that one!
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
Wait!
No!
Oh my gosh!
Cleverly done.
Yeah!
We did it, we did it, we did it.
Free balls, too.
Whoa!
Purple peg is worth big points.
Score over 25,000 points on a shot to get a free ball.
Oh my god!
He's killing that guy!
He's killing the peg-o-man!
Alright, we're gonna try and sneak in here.
Yo, there's TF2 in this, too!
Oh!
Dun, dun, dun!
Free ball!
Dang it.
But we got the magic ball.
Let's- Let's- Do that.
Long shot!
Oh, magic ball!
Big boost!
Gaming, gaming, gaming, gaming, gaming, gaming!
Nice.
Alright.
Guys, this isn't a game about luck.
It's a game about absolute wit.
Minta doesn't need to hear all this.
She's a highly trained professional.
Yeah.
Watch this.
Oh.
It was a tactical retreat.
It was a tactical retreat!
Come on!
There we go.
Nice!
Dang it.
I have five balls.
Half life, full life consequences!
My gold Jimmy Lightning!
No!
This guy- Jimmy's- Jimmy's dead!
Jimmy is dead!
Oh my gosh.
No!
Guys, are we gonna make it?
Oh, wow.
Guys, I only have three balls left.
I'm scared.
I'm scared, you guys.
Wait, wait, wait.
No, no, no, no, no, no!
We gotta get rid of this.
Oh my god!
The French version of Peggle 2 is full of...
of innuendos?
No way.
Guys, we got...
I don't wanna say it was edging, but...
I mean...
We hit the edge.
Actually, it was.
We hit the edge of the orange piece, right?
Great shot.
Go, my final ball!
Ten thousand!
No, no!
Oh, there we go!
You did well!
Oh my god!
Yeah, heavy weapons guy!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Oh, there he is!
The ball will head where you click.
You're doing your shot with the mouse wheel.
Wait, really?
Oh, yeah.
I forgot about that.
Why is Peggle Horse...
with a bandana like Solid Snake?
Heavy weapons guy.
Infinite ammo.
Why don't I have infinite balls, then?
Stupid horse.
Yippee!
Oh, oh, oh!
Oh my god!
No, no, no, no!
Ah!
I'm a big fan of John Freeman.
Who is Gordon Freeman's brother.
No way!
Where do we want to go?
One second.
I'm going to move myself up just a tad.
There we go.
You don't see my big forehead so much.
We got to get in here.
So let's break it open a little bit.
Oh, oh, oh!
Even a little bit.
Purple!
No!
Free ball!
Let's go.
Nice!
Oh!
Bank.
If I go in here...
We got to get over here, too.
Oh, there's so many options.
She's goaded, Your Honor.
I know.
We still have eight balls.
We're pretty good.
But there's still a lot left.
Okay.
I'm just going to have to get rid of this one.
And hope for the best.
Come on!
Yeah!
Wow!
Guys!
We're killing it.
For real.
Long shot!
Oh!
Six balls.
Okay.
I'm going to do this.
And then bring it back.
Bring it back.
Nice.
Oh.
That was not so good.
Vivica, I thank you for the gift.
Thank you.
Oh!
I didn't even see that.
Free ball.
You guys were killing it.
Oh!
Four ball.
Oh my god!
Did you see the new game Mouthwashing?
I saw Laimu play.
Might be a good choice for Spooktober.
Overwhelmingly positive.
And short.
Mouthwashing?
What does that entail?
Oh!
What a waste.
100,000!
Weird sci-fi horror game.
You did well!
Thank you, Happy!
The dire situation gets dire-er.
Oh dear.
These awful monsters are everywhere.
There's no turning back now, friends.
We've got to give them everything we've got.
Shoot balls!
Make bounces!
Extreme fever is our only hope.
The creatures are advancing faster than we thought.
The sentry guns are our only chance to secure the perimeter.
Oh my god.
Um...
You can't see his face because it's behind me, but he looks so excited to murder.
Honestly, same.
Who knew that Peggle got so serious?
Ah!
Nyah!
Get in there.
Roll, roll, roll, roll, roll, roll!
Oh my gosh, you got everything but the orange.
So extreme you mean.
Yes!
So extreme.
Pink, bonk, pink, bonk!
Free ball, free ball!
We need to get in like here.
Yeah, like that.
Yeah, yeah.
A little, ugh.
Okay.
Oh, could've gone better.
I could've gone better.
Nice.
Guys, I'm scared.
This BGM sounds like it's from Homestar Runner.
Does it?
Bounce, bounce, bounce.
Disappear.
Nevermind.
Oh.
Ugh!
Guys, we've only got four balls left and we got a lot to get.
Three balls left!
You guys, I'm scared.
I don't know if we'll make it.
Why aren't you making the most optimal throw every time?
Cause I'm throwing!
I am throwing!
Oh my god, no.
No, no.
Oh no!
No!
Oh my god.
Are you kidding me?
It's so over.
It's so over!
No!
Oh!
Oh no!
No!
Why is he so loud?
He's so...
He's so loud.
Oh no!
It's okay.
Oh, we get different music this time.
Wow, they're all concentrated right here.
Joseph Joestar?
Oh my gosh, you know what I watched last night?
I watched the...
This has nothing to do with JoJo, but...
I watched...
The Parkour Civilization.
I finally watched The Parkour Civilization.
I haven't watched the second one though.
Would you jump for the beef?
Yeah, every time.
I would.
I'd jump for the beef.
I would make it.
I would make it every time.
Trust.
Did you watch the two movies?
Only the first one.
I didn't watch the second one yet.
So no spoilers.
Oh my gosh, what a horrible...
Oh my god, what a horrible...
Oh my god, you guys.
That was so bad.
Hopefully...
Okay, the hope bounces all the way back over here.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Nice!
Oh wow!
Have I watched Joker 2?
No.
I heard it's like...
Have you watched Joker 2?
Yeah, I accept Parkour's payments.
In fact, don't super chat me ever again.
Only Parkour donos to me from now on.
Thank you.
Okay.
I didn't even say Joker 1.
I liked Joker.
I think it was like a little...
Maybe overhyped just a bit.
But I still liked it.
I wasn't like...
Oh, this is so bad.
I was like...
Yeah, this is...
This is good.
But...
Okay.
Guys, we only have four balls left.
I need to lock in.
Oh my gosh.
Yes!
Free ball!
Oh my gosh, thank goodness.
Okay, we have four balls.
But I heard the new one just turns into a straight up musical.
But you know me.
I don't dislike a musical, but...
Shoot 525 o'clock.
25.
Like this?
Guys!
Thank you!
I tip you with one block vertical jump.
You call that a tip?
No, I'm just kidding.
That's for babies.
Here's my one block triple spin...
Triple back spin peg champ swirl.
With a stink hop.
What does this get me, man?
You didn't have to pay so much.
What are you talking about?
Oh my god!
You get a mansion!
Keep having fun, Minto!
Thank you!
Thanks for three months!
100!
No!
More!
It went...
You did well!
Three block backwards 360 parkour dono.
Wow!
You guys are so generous today!
Thank you!
Oh my god!
Boom!
Falls into the void.
You did well!
You've got to use your head.
While you're at it, try to deny our invaders the use of theirs.
Boom!
Boom, baby!
Oh, nice.
This is the optimal...
Well, it would have been.
If I had gone in.
But it would have been the optimal shot.
The optimal shot!
Boom!
Oh, that kind of sucked.
This one seems tricky.
Boom!
Nice!
Nice.
Bonus ball!
I think?
Did I get a bonus ball?
I think it's Dust 1.
You guys are speaking in riddles to me.
This is how...
Nice!
This is how you guys feel when I talk about anything idle?
You're just like, this is...
What are you talking about?
Dust 2?
This is obviously Dust 1, you fake fan!
I recognize those particles.
Yes.
It's a Counter-Strike map.
What?
How is there Counter-Strike?
Oh my god, that one really was bad.
You guys, that one was so bad!
Okay, I'm gonna have to...
I'm gonna have to hope we get a bonus.
Yes!
Please!
More!
Yes!
Free ball!
Free ball, free ball, free ball.
Oh, that was good.
Could have been better.
But it was good.
Guys, I think we'll make it!
I think we'll make it!
We're making it out of the...
Out of the noob... the parkour noob... zone with this.
I think.
Oh god.
Three balls!
Oh, yeah, we're fine.
Never mind.
Oh!
A classic rim job.
No!
At
what point...
I actually didn't notice what score I got.
Style point...
Wait.
Oh, I got 50,000!
Maybe?
You guys, that's not an L.
10,000 is the L.
Oh, it was 10,000?
Why?
Why does it say 50,000?
I'm gonna say...
It landed in 10,000.
No...
These dreaded portals complicate matters considerably.
Use my super guide to navigate...
Wait, there's...
Oh my god.
Wait, there's actual portals.
Wait, there's actual...
The portals work?
How is this free?
This is so awesome.
Whoa!
I hate this game.
What the hell?
It went straight through.
You...
Jerk.
Oh my god.
Lucky bounce.
Let's just clear these out of the way, right?
Nice.
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Look how cute...
I love the turrets, actually.
I mean, they're obviously so annoying.
But the turrets are so cute.
I got the free ball anyway.
Holy cow.
Wait, so if I like...
Oh...
What the hell?
Oh, this is a part two.
Oh my god.
Okay, it'll hit...
That...
Oh...
Oh!
Portal!
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
So awesome.
Okay.
I wonder if the other characters...
If we'll only have Super Guide, you know?
Or if the other characters are in this too.
Hmm.
There we go.
Like that!
Come on, shy free ball!
I am a gamer!
I'm gaming, I'm gaming, I'm gaming.
Oh...
Okay, we're going to make it into the hole.
Dang it!
No!
Oh my god.
How am I gaming so hard though?
Yes!
Orange attack!
Guys!
Oh my gosh.
I have just one left...
and eight balls.
Are you kidding me?
I know that might have looked stupid, but...
I wanted the extra points.
Gaming, gaming, extreme fever!
Every time!
Why can't I at least get...
GLaDOS!
Once again, excellent work.
It makes me want to play Portal again.
The portals are multiplying at a geometric rate.
Choose your shots carefully and pay attention to your timing.
Okay.
Oh...
Okay, let's just go for it.
Timing shmiming.
I don't need timing.
See?
It's all about gamer instinct.
IP!
It's all about the gamer instinct.
Yeah.
Gamer.
Gamer instinct.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice!
Free ball.
Free ball, free ball, free ball...
Left.
What?
I have to go all the way through there?
Oh my god, this is craziness.
My instincts as a gamer.
That was insane.
That was the craziness.
That was not good.
That one was sub-optimal maybe.
Okay, physics, help me out.
There we go.
Guys,
wait.
How am I supposed to get these three?
Oh my god, do you see that?
It just leads straight down.
I need to go like...
Okay.
Use the balls.
Oh no, I don't have my...
I don't have my guide anymore.
Okay, let's try the other direction.
Nice.
Guys, I was gaming so much, I can't lose this.
Gotta get rid of that...
No, I don't think the one in the middle is...
The one in the middle is fine.
Because we need stuff to bounce off of.
Oh, come on.
If we
don't hit any pegs in a shot, you can get your ball back.
This is messed up.
Try to get the closer ones.
Like...
Let's try this direction.
Oh my goodness.
Yes!
Oh my gosh.
That just leads these two left.
Oh...
Holy moly.
If I can like bounce it like crazy, you know?
Like this maybe.
Physics!
Yes!
If only.
Guys, this is... this is too scary.
This is too scary!
Alvin, thank you for the $5.50.
Thank you!
Boom,
boom.
Slight...
no, I don't think we can do any straight shots.
See, it doesn't get close.
Here we go.
Holy cow.
Maybe a little more down?
Bouncing it off the perp?
Oh...
I don't think it'll...
Well, maybe if I like...
Like that...
Maybe like that?
Maybe...
I am using my mouse wheel.
That's what these...
These are.
Upper back.
Or, I like this blue.
This one.
Oh...
Okay okay okay.
Oh, I can go more down.
Damn.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna go like here.
In between.
Okay, here we go.
Once again, excellent work.
So cute!
Thank you!
They've pushed us back into the warehouse.
Fight, Peggle Masters!
Fight for our very survival!
Oh, fight, Peggle Masters!
Here's an ice jump for the game.
Impressive.
Thank you.
Fight, Peggle Masters!
We're not fighting, Peggle Masters.
It is fight.
I am a Peggle Master.
Fight for our very survival!
Oh my goodness, the companion cubes are so cute.
I always wanted to get one of those square cars and then Natasha as a companion cube.
Anyone else see a pig's face in the blue portals?
In the blue?
Oh, in these ones?
I don't...
What is that supposed to be?
I'm actually not quite sure.
Oh wow, that was horrendous.
That was horrible!
That was awful!
Oh, oh my god!
The portal freaked me out.
No, no, no!
Get this one!
Nice!
Nice, nice, nice.
I guess that made up for a little bit.
I can't tell what it is.
Don't get to drop by often.
Thanks for dropping by!
Tron05, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
I thought it would go into the portal.
We gotta get some of these.
Oh, so close to free shot.
Guys, I don't think this is the round.
I don't think this is the... I don't think this is the run.
Oh my gosh!
Scared me!
I don't think this is the run, but...
Nice.
No!
Three balls left!
This is definitely not the run.
Oh gosh.
It's okay.
It's okay!
Bye, Zek!
Thanks for the buy!
Get the thank you!
Sorry if I said your name wrong.
I'm so sorry.
Thank you so much!
Guys, I'm not speaking.
Oh yeah, there's no way.
At the Enrichment Center, we believe that if at first you don't succeed, you fail.
Actually, it's kind of worth failing so that I can see what they say at the end.
So true.
You fail.
Oh, nice.
Let's see.
I wanna get inside there.
You know?
Like that.
Could've been better.
Oh, come on.
That was not great.
Okay, that made up for it.
Frogs are great.
I'm glad you like them.
So glad.
They're really great helpers, you know?
They do such a good job.
Entertaining you guys in that part of the...
What is the...
What...
The...
The, like, hitbox, I guess, for the portal is so small.
Oh, nice.
People, my people.
Oh, it only goes from orange to blue?
It doesn't go back... the opposite either?
Oh...
Oh, nice.
Oh, my God.
Holy shoot.
That might have saved the run, you guys.
That might have just saved the run, maybe.
Oh, oh, maybe, maybe, please.
Oh, cow.
Holy,
what the, what the, what the, what the...
What a bounce.
That was insane.
Maybe I am a master after all.
I can't lose now, please.
I only have three balls left.
Oh, no.
Wait, it's okay.
I can get direct for both of these.
It is just the two of them, right?
Last ball, last shot.
Here I go.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Not ten thousand.
Hundred thousand.
Come on, ball, let's go.
Yeah.
No, turn around.
Don't go there.
Yeah.
Once again, excellent work.
Amazing.
Guys, I might be the best Peggle player ever.
I might be.
No one's done as much research as Mint.
Just look at her library.
She knows her balls.
You peggled extremely.
Not only Mint-o-balling, she bouncing.
Shady, thank you so much for the Akazuba.
Wait, that's it?
Mission accomplished.
Or is it?
Oh, no.
More creatures are appearing.
Fiercer than ever.
If you can't defeat these five challenges, it could mean the end of Peggle...
Oh, forever.
Oh,
the sun is creepy.
Continue?
So, I have to beat the challenges.
Okay.
Score over 300,000 points on this level to win this challenge.
For this one, I just need to beat the challenge.
Oh, this one...
Okay.
The level has 35 orange pegs.
Can you still hit them all?
Okay.
Challenge mode, everybody.
We only have Bjorn.
Wait a second.
This is so unfair.
Why can't I use the other guys?
They're clearly there.
Wait, what am I...
Oh, score 300,000 points.
I tried tipping a two block jump, but now I have to do it again.
Now I'm parkour prison, please don't know.
Oh...
Uh...
If I let you go, you can never...
You can never try again.
Gotta buy the full game.
What?
Full Peggle game?
I own full Peggle.
I thought this was its own thing.
I mean, it is free.
Don't get me wrong.
I'm not like...
I'm not being like...
Hey, game.
Like, I'm honestly shocked that this is free, because it's...
It's a lot.
If you want to play more Peggle, I recommend Holopop.
It's literally just Hololive Peggle.
Yeah!
Okay.
Thank you.
If you want to play more Peggle.
What do you mean by that?
I always want to play more Peggle.
Oh, wow.
Wait a second.
I have to get 300,000?
Okay.
Ugh.
Ugh!
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
What if I hit all of these though?
If I clear the board, what will happen?
I mean...
That was terrible.
Guys!
Oh no!
Parkour...
You could host parkour civilization map and make the viewers compete to become the parkour I could do that.
Or...
I pick the beef and I end up in jail.
I don't... is this even possible?
Do I just have to make only like trick shots?
Like, I have to make like crazy shots every time?
Let's see.
Let's have... how can we make a long shot, you know?
But also, like, get the purple one every time?
I think?
Maybe?
Oh, this will be a long shot, right?
What?
What's instant replay?
I see.
I'm done.
I don't need to see it again, thank you.
Oh, so that's a long shot.
Oh my gosh, that gave us big money though.
Big money, big money.
Oh, come on.
These are long shots, please!
We only got half way.
And you don't get the...
And you don't get the 100,000?
Listen!
No...
Blue pegs don't count for long shots.
Ah, okay, okay, okay.
Oh, I guess... oh, because I didn't get all the orange.
That makes sense, right?
Yeah, okay, okay, okay.
Like, I didn't technically complete it.
Okay, that makes sense.
I'm stupid.
Let's just, uh, redo.
Don't worry about it.
Long shot!
Yeah!
That's playing with portals, baby.
Try and hit the purple every shot.
Yeah, seriously.
Oh, come on!
Does this count as a long shot?
Oh, maybe that.
Yeah!
No, no, no.
No, no, no!
Don't be a shit!
Don't be!
I don't have a different... I only have Bjorn unlocked.
We got a free ball!
Big news, everybody.
Big news, big news, big news.
Oh, that was almost a long shot.
Maybe...
Let's see.
Trying to get the orange in there.
Oh my gosh.
Yes!
Oh!
We have three balls left.
VTuber, why are you bad at geometry?
What are you talking about?
Oh, shoot.
That did not go the way I thought it would.
Maybe I am bad at geometry.
Please!
100,000!
No!
Don't do this to me!
Oh my god.
The bonus.
I thought...
I thought I wasn't going to make it.
I thought I was going to be like just a couple thousand away.
Or a couple hundred away.
I mean...
Cleverly done.
Ta-da!
I am a master.
I am a master!
This area has 35 orange pegs.
That's a lot of pegs.
Whoa!
Guys, we are already killing it.
Isn't it?
We're already killin' it?
Oh, so close!
That was so close!
Come on, give me free... free ball, free ball, free ball, free ball, free ball!
Ah, so close!
Top, thanks for a month!
Thank you!
Bink, bonk, bink, bonk!
You've now surpassed... oh, that was terrible.
Wait, no, no, no!
You have surpassed Peggle.
You are now Big Peggler.
A small ghost like me?
There's no way.
Double free ball!
Ooh, I thought it would hit.
I thought it would hit.
I thought that everybody would be on...
...my side.
But I went and blew it all sky-high.
Now she won't even spare a passing glance.
All just because I...
...pegged her.
I'm too... too close to the sun.
No, don't...
Only two balls left?
I don't know, guys.
I'm not feeling it.
No, I don't think it's gonna happen.
Last ball!
I got it.
Maybe on, like, the corner, it'll, like, bounce over here.
You jump for beef...
...and rip my pants!
No!
Oh, no!
We were so close!
We were so close, you guys.
I even gamed so hard in the beginning.
I got the ultra-slide.
I got everything good.
Oh, no!
So close!
Stop it!
Stop almost making it, please!
When Big Larry came just to put him down Minto turned into a clown And no girl ever wants to dance With a ghost who went and ripped her pants
Stop the clown emojis!
You know those are there to represent you, right?
Doesn't represent me.
I'm putting on the clown, but it's to make fun of you.
You're the real clown.
Oh, gosh.
Guys, this is not the run, either.
This is not the run.
Did I speak too soon?
Have confidence.
Chat reflects the streamer.
If we're clowns, you must be, too.
No, that's not how it works.
It's that...
You...
Ref...
reflect...
Wait...
I...
I reflect the freakiness, but I...
It's not a two-way street!
It can't be!
It's not allowed!
Guys, maybe this is the run.
GUYS, MAYBE THIS IS THE RUN!
No way...
OH MY GOD!
You did well!
You did well.
That was an insane last shot.
I know, right?
We're gonna get through these challenge levels like nothing.
What's this one?
Oh, clear all pegs.
Come on.
Get in there.
Keep pegging.
Peggling?
Sorry.
Parkour Civilization Part 1.
Watch along in Mint Court on Wednesday.
Why do you say...
Why are you sad about that?
What's wrong with that?
You guys should bond.
James Bond.
Have fun.
Hang out with each other.
What's wrong with Mortal Movie Night?
Oh, I need to plan what I'm doing over the garden wall.
That was not a good one.
Do this and get in the middle of it.
Oh my gosh!
I'm getting so many free balls.
Awesome.
Oh, so close!
The free ball!
There's a Discord.
I thought you took it down.
It's not.
It's a fan run Discord.
It's not me.
Oh, I did hear... Wait.
Stop Motion Short on November 3rd.
Is that what they're... Oh, they announced it.
I, um...
I, uh...
Actually, Leah sent me, like, a... What's it called?
They're releasing a vinyl and stuff.
Which I'm very excited about.
But, um...
Why is it on November 3rd?
Over the Garden Wall is a Halloween show.
I don't understand.
Really?
Seriously?
Okay, let's get in here first before we go for the individuals.
This sucks!
Oh, free ball!
Okay, okay.
Nice, nice, nice.
Yeah...
I don't know.
I do want to watch it, obviously, but...
I imagine it'll probably be kind of short if it's stop motion.
Who's getting pegged tonight?
Peggled!
Close.
Yeah, we were really close.
Keep going.
No!
You should have kept going!
Oh, nice.
That was a good one.
Oh!
Oh, that was pretty good.
That was pretty good.
Why didn't you just win?
I don't know, man.
Either they couldn't release it on time or the publishers decided on a date where people have more money to spend.
They're like, they're like, yeah, you got to stop thinking about Halloween.
You got to...
November?
That's... that's Christmas month.
What the... stupid shot.
Please, Peggle.
If we can get these, we can get, hopefully, extra...
Ball, but also...
I'll take that, too.
Maybe, like...
Maybe in there.
That works?
This works?
No, everyone knows as soon as October... or as soon as November starts...
It's time to start thinking about Christmas, baby!
No one cares about...
Anything else in November.
Apparently.
Christmas gets two whole months.
November is Thanksgiving month in the USA, is it not?
It is.
But no one cares.
Well, I stand corrected.
Corporations do not care.
No, they say, get those Christmas lists in, baby.
That one was not good.
Free ball.
We got two balls left, but we have quite a few things.
There you go.
Will you go for the purple peg or the blue?
Blue.
Last ball.
Guys, we were so close.
We were so close.
Imagine if I had, like, gamed that, you know?
Come on.
Okay.
That wasn't so bad, actually.
I want it to bounce... like that.
We need to get it in... like, into it, you know?
We gotta get it, like, infiltrating the little... the little pegs.
What are the frogs dancing to?
Everything.
They're dancing to...
Dang it.
That should have been a free ball.
Games over be...
The games over be, like, TF2.
Oh, no.
Portal, you failed.
I have, like, two...
You fucking died.
You stupid...
Oh, my God.
Guys, this isn't the run.
I say that and then I get a free ball.
And it always gives me more confidence.
I don't think so, though.
I don't think this is the run.
Oh, my God.
Another free ball.
Games, stop giving me this false hope.
Please.
Please stop giving me false hope.
Ah.
Oh, no.
Oh, I thought...
I thought...
I miscalculated.
Bounce, bounce, bounce...
Bounce?
Oh, I only have one ball.
What was that?
I was trying to make it go like this.
Boing...
Like that.
I don't know.
It's a...
It was my last ball.
The purple wouldn't have done any difference.
I think.
I think the purple would have just...
Laughed at me.
Third time's the charm.
This might be our toughest one yet.
Half Life 2 has a really good spooky section if you ever want to give it a try.
Really?
What kind of spooky are we talking about?
Nice.
I did not mean to do it like that.
That's silly of me.
That was so silly of me.
That was so silly.
Let's see.
How do I want to do this?
How do we want to approach?
Isn't there one that's like a VR game?
That's... can be kind of spooky.
Oh, nice!
Half Life Alyx.
Ah!
I haven't played any...
Any Half Life games though.
What should I...
What would you start at?
Just one?
First time joining in stream.
Thanks!
Hello!
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Black Mesa.
Oh...
What's the release order?
Oh!
I was so wrong.
I was So Clooose....
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
Made some lemon potsa pong to go along with my grilled chicken tonight, but I was too slow and now...
It will have to set up overnight.
Huh?
Black Mesa is Half Life 1, remastered.
Ah, okay, okay, okay.
Oh, guys...
I suck.
Go with the original, it still holds up.
Have you guys seen the new...
Until Dawn...
Remake?
Honestly, I keep seeing people posting like...
Wow, this is what old Until Dawn looks like, and this is what new Until Dawn looks like.
And I can't tell which is which.
I'm like...
Which is the...
Which is the old one?
Oh, man...
It's not great.
It's...
Oh, it's...
I'm never gonna get sponsored by them.
Yeah...
Oh!
Dang it!
I think they had to remaster it.
Or rather, had to, quote-unquote, because...
Apparently, you couldn't play it on...
Like, there was something wrong with the PC version.
And so...
They...
Remade it...
For...
That.
But, I don't know...
It's also so silly.
I think it was something about moving it to a new engine.
I don't know.
I don't know exactly.
And I'm not an expert.
So, I'm not gonna...
Really...
I don't know.
But...
I should pay attention.
Okay.
I'm not locked in, you guys.
In fact...
In fact, we're regressing.
Oh!
We're regressing!
Locked out.
We're locked out, you guys.
Ahhhh!
I wonder if they changed anything in it, though?
Orange attack!
Free Ball!
Nice.
I'll take it.
Oh, oh!
Oh!
Nice!
Mmm.
Oh, come on!
Come on!
And it avoided literally everything in there!
You sucker, you...
Trying to go for the...
purple one, so maybe I can get a free ball!
Double free ball!
Seems like they changed some stuff, like music and camera angles.
Oh, really?
I don't think I'll...
play it, let alone stream it, though.
If you were wondering.
But...
Oh!
But you know.
Then there's also the...
What?
The other...
It's super massive, right?
There's the other one that's...
God damn!
It's like a space one, I think it is.
Oh.
Please no spamming!
Yeah, it's like a...
It feels like...
It feels like The Thing.
You know?
Like the movie?
Like, it seems like The Thing kind of plot.
But you're in space, and...
Callisto Protocol!
Yes, yes, yes, yes!
That's the one, that's the one.
Oh my God!
Please.
This is so bad.
At least give me a free ball!
Just...
Oh, come on!
I hate this game!
I hate this challenge!
No!
Let's just do it.
We'll go back to that one.
This level has 45 pegs.
And then this one's 350.
We got 350...
No, we didn't get 350,000.
But we could try.
Alright, guys.
We need big money.
Wow!
Nice!
Oh my God!
I'm here for that.
I hate this game.
Same studio as Dead Space.
Callisto Prodigal?
Wait, maybe I'm thinking of a different game then.
No, it's definitely the Until the Dawn people.
It's definitely the Until Dawn people.
Oh my God, no.
Hold on, I'm gonna look it up.
Now it's gonna bother me.
Because I don't think it's out yet either.
Um...
Until the Dawn in Space.
The Dark Pictures Anthology.
What is it called?
What?
Come
on!
I got this!
Directive 8020.
Oh, you guys were all saying it in the chat.
Directive...
80...
Yeah, that one.
Oh my God, go to purple.
Free ball?
No!
Look how many points we're already at though.
That's kind of insane.
Oh my gosh!
Free ball!
Guys?
First I've heard of that game.
It's not out yet.
I think they just kind of talked about it.
First...
Oh, here we go.
Dang it.
Can we get to the purple up there?
Wouldn't that be insane?
Like that!
Oh no, we didn't make it!
Wait.
Okay.
Come on.
100,000, baby.
100,000.
Even though I'm sad about my dessert not being finished, my bacon-wrapped jalapeno pepper jack stuffed chicken breast turns out good.
Gosh, Kinky, you need to just open a restaurant.
Cleverly done.
Done!
Okay.
45 gold pegs.
Let's try it.
45?
This is insane.
We've busted over 300k.
Yeah, baby!
Yeah, we are!
Free ball!
Why didn't you disappear?
Yo!
Oh my god.
It just literally went circled around it.
You asshole.
Come on.
Ah!
Man.
Man, man.
So happy to be playing this with you guys tonight.
Thanks for being here.
I really appreciate it.
Thanks guys for watching me.
Hehe.
Nice.
Oh, that one will break.
Yeah, okay.
Hehe.
Bink-bonk!
Yeah!
That's bink-bonk!
We only have four left though.
Quite a bit.
Quite a few.
Wait, this will be a long shot.
Maybe we'll get lucky.
No.
Three balls left and quite a bit to go.
Oh gosh.
For ones like that, I really need to like...
wait for it to maybe...
be underneath.
Last ball.
We got pretty close though.
Your emails are the best.
Oh, I'm glad you think so.
I'm glad you like them.
Thank you.
Oh no!
I'm not watching you.
I'm just here for the cool frogs on the stream.
Honestly?
I get it.
You're here for heavy.
What about me?
Nice.
Get in there.
Peckle, peckle, peckle, peckle, peckle!
I love playing blackjack!
Oh my god!
Frog... what?
What is frog?
Frog fractions.
No, I've never played that.
What is that?
Hopefully...
I was gonna say, hopefully it goes further than what it looks to do, but...
Oh come on, come on, come on, come on, come on!
Can you move over?
You're blocking my ocean.
Frog factions is a spooky indie game.
Oh really?
I saw a lot of people playing Zoo-co-sis recently.
No one's asked me to play it, but I'm just gonna say I won't ever play it.
I can't play games like that.
That like, involve sick animals.
I will just cry the entire time.
I'll be so sad.
I'll never play it.
I'm really sorry.
I don't even know if it's any good or not.
But I can't actually play it.
I will literally just be...
Sad girl.
Guys, wait, we have three balls left.
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
Guys, I think we've done it!
Oh, that was me saying it.
You did well!
Oh, my bad.
Oh, wait, hold on.
I'm gonna move myself back over.
Alright.
One final challenge, guys.
Zoo-co-sis has some wildly realistic animal distress noises that makes...
That it makes me more uncomfortable than the horror stuff.
Oh, yeah, see, I...
Oh, no, no, no.
That sounds way too specific of mechanics to be enjoyable then.
Oh, well, good.
Then I won't...
I'm not gonna play it.
Let her rip!
Trust my instincts.
Oh.
Wait, I'm not...
Hold on.
Pause.
There we go.
My bad.
I saw they're making a new Alien Isolation.
That's exciting.
A game that scares me too much.
That's a game that scares me a lot.
Oh, yeah, I've not played the first one.
Scary.
But I like Alien movies.
I've watched the Let's Play of it.
I remember...
Gosh, do you guys remember when that game first came out and everyone was just like, Boo, this game is way too slow.
Where's the alien?
Where...
And now everyone is like obsessed with it.
What happened?
Now they're making a new one and everyone's just like, Yeah!
Everyone was just like, Oh, my God.
Alien just doesn't show up enough.
Not scary.
Two out of ten.
The game grew on people.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
I only have three balls.
No!
This one is so hard.
I know I'm probably...
I'm also just like shooting willy-nilly.
I'm not really thinking right now.
I
don't know what the stride is here.
I'm just going to shoot into the corner.
Hope for the best.
Oh, fuck.
Anyway.
Shoot to the corner.
Yeah, I get these little corner bits, you know.
I'm a peg-goal master, you guys.
I've mastered the peg.
I can get this final challenge.
I can do it.
I am Mint Phantom.
No.
Nice.
Please, free ball.
Free ball.
Yes.
Double.
Yeah.
The M&M stands for...
No.
Not Master Peg or Master Peg-ler.
We're in good shape here, guys.
Oh, my God.
Imagine if I said we're in good shape here, guys.
I missed.
Holy cow.
Dang it.
Ruined my shot.
Oh, my God.
That was in luck.
That was pure skill.
Baby.
Nice.
Oh, my God.
The
L is silent.
No, it's not.
No,
it's...
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God, oh, my God.
Two balls left, you guys.
Oh
my god.
Is this it?
Is this the final one?
I would like to dedicate this to dancing froggies in the corner.
This one's for you!
You!
Ultra extreme!
And we still get in the corner.
Congratulations!
Incredible.
Amazing.
You defeated them utterly.
Now you're ready to get the full version of Bagel and Master.
I already own the full version of Bagel.
Oh my god.
This is just a big ol' ad.
I beat the demo.
I am so awesome.
Now I need to get the full version.
Donating for the full version of Bagel.
I already...
I've already beat the full version of Bagel.
Wait, can we duel?
Fight off against a friend?
Hey, who wants to be my friend?
Let's do Toasty.
Where...
Who the hell is Jimmy Lightning?
Huh?
Wait, who...
Oh.
Play with a friend.
What?
I can't even...
I can't even put his...
You gave him that name.
I can't even put it in there.
Jimmy Lighten.
Never seen a more professional pegler in my life.
Thank you.
Johnny Sasaki.
Why won't it let me put in the K?
What?
Sasaki...
It only lets me...
Wait, is my K key broken?
No?
Johnny...
Sa...
Sasai.
Johnny Acai Bowl.
Johnny...
Acai.
Okay...
Mintos turn...
Wait, oh...
Oh, I thought it was going to be online.
Um...
I was going to invite you guys to play.
I'll shoot for you, okay?
This is Minto's turn.
Your turn.
Oh, you got one.
You got an orange.
Good job.
Okay, Minto's turn.
Nice.
Yeah, good, good.
Your turn!
Awww, Johnny!
Johnny!
Johnny, what are you doing?
Get your head in the game, come on!
Oh my gosh, I almost had an extra ball.
Johnny's turn.
Johnny!
You're gonna get penalized.
You're gonna keep getting penalized.
Johnny's turn.
Sounds so aggressive.
It's such an aggressive like...
It's like watching a person play chess alone.
Minto's last ball!
Just kidding!
Oh, Johnny's turn.
Minto!
You guys got 420!
Go
away!
And I got 42160!
Alright, frogs, get off the screen.
Get off the screen, frogs!
Get off the screen!
Goodbye, goodbye.
Goodbye, frogs, goodbye.
Um...
This is like the crispiest...
If you guys want some crispy, crunchy ASMR...
This is it!
This is the crispiest, crunchiest ASMR.
We let you win, you're welcome.
Thank you!
Crunchy.
It's so crunchy.
A master pegler like you should definitely check out Peglin.
I do know Peglin.
Now that I think about it.
I remember being told about Peglin before.
I think I looked it up.
Yield!
Thank you for the five gifted.
Thank you!
What happened to Bjorn?
Don't worry about it.
In fact, I am going to make that shut up though.
I'm not going to talk for too long because...
Sorry.
Shorter stream today.
Because I...
Um...
I am...
You know...
Letting my voice recover a little bit.
Give me a second.
What do we want to listen to?
This one?
What's this one?
This one is chill.
Give me one second.
Where am I?
Oh!
Wait a second.
I got to fix something.
I got to fix it.
There I am!
Invisible ghost.
What happened to me?
Why?
Why did I freeze?
I'm back.
Boneless ghost.
You guys.
3.0.
Coming up.
Big stuff.
Big news.
Actually I paid...
A lot of people I needed to pay.
Today.
I paid a lot of people I needed to pay today.
So...
Um...
Wait a second.
Something is wrong.
Give me a second.
There we go.
Oh, I think that happened.
Um...
Yeah.
Oh!
Empty wallet!
Yeah!
No, I was only...
I've only been able to get all the stuff that I've been getting.
Um...
Because of you guys help.
Hopefully...
It's basically like new...
Everything.
Like new...
New music.
New intro.
Um...
What else?
Minto project tags.
Thank you Turtles!
Thank you!
And another secret thing that...
Will be released on that day.
Yeah, yeah.
So...
New background.
Actually...
I think this is the only thing that will remain the same.
Will we see Mintos in 3.0?
Uh...
Maybe.
Try Princess Thank You!
Yeah, so...
Hmm...
The background...
I guess the background is kind of new.
It's newer than my old background, right?
You heard her guys pay up.
No!
No, no, no.
Save for you.
Thank you!
Thank you Flowerworks!
Thank you for 4 months!
Will we lose bouncy Chibi Minto?
No, no.
Actually, I might even ask them to update...
Chibi Minto to be...
Uh...
To...
To new Minto.
Since there's a few little bit of changes.
Like with the outfit.
And other stuff.
Yeah.
Did you hear that Hideaki Anno is making a space battleship Yamato movie?
No way!
Really?
But yeah, Chibi Minto will stay.
Um...
But...
You know, my...
It's my...
Full...
Apparition that will...
Kind of cease.
But not cease.
It will transform.
To a different form.
It will become...
Evolved.
It's like...
I'm like a Pokemon.
Except I become the same.
But a little different.
A Mighty Morphin Minto Ranger.
Yeah, yeah.
So...
She's gonna be dead.
I mean...
I am dead.
Oh, sorry.
Sudden crunchy jumpscare.
I'm exiting out of the game.
Today's my birthday, Gerard!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, Dear Gerard.
Happy birthday!
To you.
Whoouu Happy birthday!
I really just wanted...
I don't know.
Not like a restart.
But just...
I wanted to feel...
New, but kind of the same.
I mean, it's going to be a lot of new stuff.
I guess I wanted it for... it's really, I think, mainly, mostly for myself.
To feel kind of...
Because, you know, when I came back, I had everything the same.
As when I first left, so...
It's...
It almost feels like I never...
Like, I, you know...
And I wasn't sure how long I'd stick around.
But...
It's...
So, I didn't get anything new, you know?
I just kind of was like, okay, I'll come back.
So, I wanted to feel a little bit more official, I suppose.
I guess the best way to put it.
So, official comeback!
After, like, eight months of being here.
Or seven months?
Wait, I came back April, May, June, July, August, September, October.
Seven months!
Well, it's the end of October.
Almost eight months.
Treat yourself.
This is a threat.
No!
I'm just going to put it back towards...
I'm going to put it back towards the debut!
I'll say it until I'm blue in the face.
Glad you're still with us, babe.
Thank you!
Jack's back, baby!
She's counting on her fingers right now.
How'd you know that?
Don't call me...
Don't call me out for that.
I'll say it until I'm boneless!
What did she mean by that?
One of life's and afterlife's big mysteries.
Thank you for officially telling us after seven months that you're officially staying...
You couldn't tell from a new debut?
You couldn't tell!
Why would I debut?
If...
If I was going to leave!
Last time you debuted a new model, you graduated.
But...
That was...
Different.
I...
Made a new model...
And then...
Uh...
Heaven called forth.
I made...
I started a new model!
I started 2.0 before...
Before I...
Before Heaven called for me!
Otherwise I never would have made it!
Oh my gosh.
Keio, thank you!
Paying my dues for being a long time clip watcher.
Give up the good work.
Awww!
Thank you!
Thanks for dropping by!
Thank you so much for the akasupa!
Thank you so so so much!
I saw the light and then...
I dropped back down.
I was like...
Oh, Heaven?
I belong in Hell!
She hates us real.
She hates us REAL!
We...
Go and be sad if you leave, champ.
No!
I'm here.
This is our outer Heaven.
Literally.
Literally, I'm in outer Heaven right now.
How...
How perfect for...
Specifically me.
Hahaha.
We're...
Where the Minto sans frontier are.
You're...
Assumed!
Oh thank you, David.
So is Grocer Minto officially out of the picture now?
I guess so.
It still always makes me nervous though.
I'm extremely comfortable, you know?
Where I'm at.
I'm not saying like, oh, I need to be the biggest Vatobar.
I need to be bigger.
I love exactly where I'm at.
But, you know...
It always makes me worried.
What if one day my YouTube channel just gets kaput?
What if YouTube decides to be like...
You spied animals once too many times.
Which was one time.
And they decide to shut down my channel.
Then I have nothing.
And I'm like, oh god...
I'm out of a job.
Still never did that 250k stream.
Oops.
What should we do?
For 250k.
There's a one block jump.
Will you be changing the Minto voice too?
Yeah, I'm gonna talk like this from now on.
It's like frog poop but tough.
That's what I'm gonna...
That's what I'm gonna talk and I'm gonna sound like.
It's the only voice I've got.
Oh, you're my inspiration.
Thank you for staying with us Minto forever.
Thank you!
This is the same energy as everyone telling John Wick is back in the first movie and denying the rumors.
Wait, I don't know.
I don't understand this reference.
Glad to have you officially back Minto.
Thank you!
Debut a new outfit on April 1st.
Title it announcement.
How do you know I'm not gonna debut a new outfit on April 1st?
Mint goth maid model win.
Mint retirement fund tax.
You sound like my mom.
Okay, let's make a goth maid right now.
Okay, hold on.
Let's see.
Let's make a goth maid right now.
Okay, this.
Wait, how can I make it this?
Let's see.
Build a goth Vtuber.
I can't keep the white stripes though.
Wait, what is this deal?
Oh, never mind.
Never mind.
Okay.
There's that.
Let's see.
This part.
Wait, that's the white ruffles.
We'll keep the white ruffles.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Why is this so hard?
Oh wait, you guys can't see anything.
Hold on.
There we go.
It's this one, right?
No, that's the ruffles.
Let's see.
If I just make it all black, it's hard to see.
Actually, we'll just keep it like that.
Actually, it looks very traditional, doesn't it?
Looks so traditional.
We'll make it a little bit more grayish.
And you...
Wait, what was the color that I did?
Something like that.
Okay.
And we gotta get the back.
The back.
Um...
Wait, which part is it?
No.
Let's see.
Oh, there we go.
Yeah.
Like that.
We're doing this in real time, guys.
We're doing this in real time.
Oops, wrong thing.
Let's see.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Got it.
Like around there.
Okay.
Let's do the garter belt.
Can I?
Can I do the garter belt?
There we go.
Oh.
Just like that.
Oh, we gotta do the bows.
We gotta do the bows.
Add purple for extra goth.
Oh, we'll make the bows purple.
We'll make the bows purple.
Like that.
Like so.
I know.
This is...
This is maybe a little bit of...
Immersion breaking.
I'm sorry.
But...
It's kinda cool to see.
Like this is...
Kind of how...
I'm made up.
You know?
And we can do my...
We can do my...
Bow tie...
Oh my god.
We can do...
The one on my neck too.
And then...
This one?
How do I make it more purple?
Hmm...
Maybe like that.
Oh wait.
We are doing it.
What the?
No no.
There we go.
Like that?
Saying you're messing with your colors made me remember you could remove your skirt.
Mayhaps carry on with Minto 3.0.
Honestly, I haven't tried yet.
I haven't tried yet, actually.
I'm not sure if it will be a thing.
I'll try, I'll try.
Okay.
Okay!
The brown doesn't really match, but whatever.
And for my hair?
I wonder...
Let's see...
How can we...
Oh!
It looks so cute!
Oh, wait.
I'm like dying my hair in real time.
This is crazy.
There we go.
You guys!
That's so cute.
Now I gotta move her.
Help!
I'm fine.
I think I messed up, you guys.
Um, wait.
I can fix it.
There we go.
Wait, no, no!
Wait, oh no!
No!
Wait, I got to get the color again.
Wait, what was the color?
Okay, I got it.
Okay.
There we go, there we go, there we go, there we go, there we go, there we go.
Wait, how do I fix that part though?
Wait.
Nope, nope, nope.
Oh, there we go, there we go, there we go, there we go.
Oh, that's where I messed up.
Sorry if this is so boring.
I'm like invested now, you guys.
I'm like invested.
I need to finish this.
I need to finish my art.
I need to finish my art, okay?
I'm invested, I'm invested.
It's not boring?
Okay.
You don't have to lie.
You can tell me the truth.
There we go!
No?
I'm gothy now.
Goth mean toe.
Oh, the hair bows.
You're right, you're right.
Let's fix that.
Or make them purpley.
Yeah, like that.
One...
And two...
And...
Three.
There we go!
I'm... but I'm not mint.
My identity.
My identity!
If I'm not mint, what am I?
Why?
I'm lilac.
I'm grape.
Oh.
This honestly reminds me of using the Gaia online hack.
Tech to find outfits and messing with the layers.
Wait, I have no idea what that is.
I'm...
Lavender.
Noted aphrodisiac.
No!
What is wrong with you?
Made eggplant.
We changed my...
Changed my oshi...
My oshi mark to an eggplant.
Grapefanta.
Well guys, this is fun.
Thanks for hanging out with me.
And letting me become made lilac.
Just for this special...
This special moment.
This is it.
Otsumito everybody!
Otsumito.
Thanks for hanging out with me.
Ako bitashikaru.
I gotta let my voice rest a little bit more.
Can we say googly eyed mint?
Pretty sure you can say this alpha toggle as a preset if you ever want to bust your out in jumpscare chat when you feel extra silly.
I'm always silly.
No!
That is not solid mint!
How do I save?
It's not perfect though.
Sorry I couldn't get some of the colors... absolutely.
It was very... it's rush job.
It's rush job.
I missed all the video games, you look cute.
Thanks for the super chat!
Thanks for dropping by, but anyway, you know.
Maya knows?
Okay.
I'll ask Maya.
Otsu lilac.
No!
Otsu Minto!
I'm always Minto!
Please!
I'm always Minto.
Oh wait, this is the extra goth aesthetic.
There you go.
Grab the lilac.
No!
New ocean lock.
I'm still the same!
Okay.
Anyway, whatever.
See you guys later.
Otsu whatever.
Or whatever.
Okay.
Like, bye.
Okay, bye.
Okay.
Okay, like...
Bye!
Otsu whatever.
Life is pain and suffering.
That's why I'm dead.
Bye!
Woah, that's kinda freaky.
Stop, I'm falling in love.
Oh my god, you're such a freak!
Okay, goodbye freaks.
Bye freaks!
Bye bye!
Thank you guys!
Thanks for hanging out with me today!
Bye bye!
Hold on, I have something to put in the...
I have something to put in my menu!
I have a new menu item!
One moment.
I have a new menu item.
Wait, oh, one second.
I gotta put it in the right folder though.
Oh, oh wait.
Eh?
Ah!
Oh!
Here, here, here!
There we go, there we go, there we go!
And then...
First menu item.
Add to menu.
Add menu.
Done, done.
Done!
Official...
Mint Phantom!
Oh, uh, mint Phantom official hoppy pre-ordered at yeahlights.com Get your mint hoppies everybody!
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Okay, bye-bye!